昨天我看到一個在 Hacker News 上的案例，他們提出了一個想法，說 AI 智能體應該直接瀏覽你的網站，而不是透過呼叫 API 來跟系統互動。這讓我覺得挺出乎意料的。
確實，這點很有趣。因為我們通常的認知是，如果要讓 AI 應用程式與你的後端系統溝通，最正規、最安全的方式就是提供一套定義好的 API。
對啊，就像我們平常在用 App，後面一定會跟某個伺服器交換資料，而那個交換的管道就是 API。現在他們卻說，讓 AI 直接「看」你的網站就好，聽起來是不是有點…像個人類？
沒錯，聽起來像是模仿人類瀏覽器操作的模式。一般公司之所以不這樣做，主要考量會是效率、穩定性和安全性。直接操作前端介面通常比呼叫專用 API 更慢，也更容易受到介面變動的影響。
而且，如果你的網站介面改版了，那是不是 AI 的操作邏輯就得重新學習？聽起來蠻麻煩的。
這就是他們挑戰的點。原文提到，他們比較了幾種讓 AI 代理在網站上運作的架構，像是 RAG 機器人、API 工具代理、程式碼編寫沙盒，然後對比他們提出的「DOM-native execution」。
DOM-native execution，聽起來像是直接在網頁結構上執行。那具體是怎麼做到的呢？他們說有三種方式會讓你「維護一個平行的工程界面」。
他們認為，前面三種方式都等同於你得另外為 AI 應用寫一套溝通介面。而 DOM-native execution 則是讓 AI 直接透過瀏覽器引擎，去理解和操作網站的 HTML、CSS 這些元素，就像人眼看到網頁、滑鼠點擊按鈕一樣。
意思是，他們讓 AI 模仿使用者，直接在網頁上「看圖說故事」？但這樣，AI 是怎麼知道要在哪個地方點擊、輸入什麼內容呢？
這需要 AI 具備更強的理解能力，能夠解析網頁的語義結構。他們強調，網站的 DOM 本身就包含了即時狀態、用戶認證和權限，這些都是現成的，不需要再為 AI 另外開發。
這樣一來，對於想把 AI 應用到自家業務的創業者或主管來說，這提供了什麼新的思路呢？
最大的啟發是，你可能不需要投入大量資源去開發新的 API，來為 AI 服務。你可以思考，現有的網頁操作流程，是否能直接被 AI「學會」和「執行」。
這樣可以大幅降低 AI 導入的門檻，對吧？尤其是中小企業，資源有限，如果能直接利用現有介面，那真的是省下一大筆開發費用。
是的，它鼓勵我們重新審視既有的數位資產。如果你的網站已經能讓人類員工處理複雜的業務，那理論上，AI 智能體也能以類似方式完成。這讓我們重新思考「AI 自動化」的定義。
那對於我們這些一般的上班族呢？這個概念能不能帶到我們的工作或生活中？
我覺得這個概念提醒我們，在解決問題時，不一定要循規蹈矩地為新技術「量身訂做」一套全新的流程。有時候，換個角度，利用現有的工具和介面，也許就能達到同樣甚至更好的效果。
就像我們在做一些重複性高的電腦操作時，是不是可以想想看，有沒有工具能直接「看」著我的螢幕，然後幫我把這些點擊、輸入的動作給自動化？
沒錯。它鼓勵一種「善用現有資源」的創新思維。不需要一切都從零開始，而是去思考如何讓新技術能更好地融入和利用既有環境。
這樣聽起來，其實是一種更務實、更有效率的創新方式。它不追求「完美介面」，而是看重「實際產出」。
可以這麼說。這個案例讓我們看到，有時候最直接的路徑，反而能帶來意想不到的效率和便利。它挑戰了我們對 AI 整合方式的固有認知。
就像一個智能小助手，不是要你幫它整理好所有文件，而是它自己就能在你的電腦裡找到需要的資料，然後幫你處理好一樣。
這個比喻很貼切。它降低了 AI 應用的複雜度，讓我們能更聚焦在核心業務問題，而不是技術介面整合上。
這樣看來，這個點子確實很有意思，給了我們一個全新的視角。